welcome to this video playing unsat sue
you have a good score against this
person so let's hope that continues even
in my current slump playing an Italian
game let's see what he's doing with
Bishop c5 on what to see exactly going
for don't want this kind of thing also
possible playing with Bishop e7 what I
don't know here is those ideas with a
quick d 5 MP is going for that I'm
trying to play without castling just
develop no i don't i don't really want
to help him with training stuff yeah
okay then he will turn here but at least
that activates by Queen a little bit ok
so do I good before yeah I think I do
that's not a bad idea man this b5 movie
solo is threatening a 7 a bit ok
so like a good gag it again some space
iam I wonder if before as an idea maybe
is going to be six after that let's
develop that's probably better night c4
as a possible idea that's a good square
anyway ok so we five and 85 hangs ok
it's giving me that pawn I'm trying to
play quickly I don't want to I had games
really in that slump where I was like up
everything and just lost some time so
let's not play in a super slow super
slow fashion ok so if i'm checking now
my e4 pawn this bit bit on the check but
i cannot really move the Queen south hmm
difficult I can go to d3 attacking his
Bishop there it's not so bad actually
miss bishop is night I mean t7 also
Quincy for as a possible
also night be three actually night be
three at Quincy for that actually looks
quite good it's going back that's
surprising I can take p7 huh I don't see
why not yet another pawn ok so he just
continues like nothing happens or
nothing happened to a five and then to
c6 I guess ok if it takes well if you
can t can take a five and night c4 maybe
if I go Queen III it's possible hmm but
where else ok I can go to c6 with check
27 anyway if i go here and he takes a
535 queen 87 and I don't really see a
big problem ok wants to go Quinn to Jeff
oh ok
rook to d3 is a bit annoying really if i
go to c6 the problem is that he can take
on f3 sometimes and then queen age 32
bit under moon yes ready
amazing that's really a dangerous threat
rook t3
night 91 looks really really ugly night
you won I see don't see her an
alternative at the moment and I cannot
wait longer I thought that would just
straight stuff but maybe he has 92 92 or
something weird maybe ID to that
threatens nighty tune okay a chick c7
hmm i really wonder can I can I do
something active like Quincy 7 Roxy age
don't don't they have something active
there I don't see it or be six or
something you know I really don't want
to play a defensive move iam
hmm i don'ts I don't see one I really
don't see a good one I can go to you
three but that definitely is bigger i
can take a quick phone I what a
nightmare really a nightmare this game
again yeah at the end I have queen bee
70 k 7 as my idea now just blundered two
pawns for nothing and then he got some
miraculous counterplay that i really
don't understand why why where that was
coming from it's really weird okay now
it starts to find good moves great okay
if he takes them still have to see
protect you seven how does he protected
JX he has neither three Maivia that that
could win maybe that wins yeah that wins
Queen f1 king edge to neither three
check wins let's see maybe sees it maybe
not probably he will see that check no
okay so if i go here i'll check now i
know i have don't have time check
g7 is tough to defend he has no way to
defend that he had a fourth checkmate I
didn't see takes Knight Teague's I
wonder if I can win this now Jake stakes
hey guys i will check it check that was
the idea okay okay that that shall win
but i only have nine seconds ah why
didn't it why did i do that it wins but
ok at the time
black resin on this is Nigel okay maybe
I will manage that it's a bit it's a bit
much yeah it was very lucky he came here
to check made a pretty simple one
actually check no we'd never check mate
why didn't you have a check made why
isn't that made I don't see it here I
thought just made I have king g3 ah good
heavens ok that is made which are
soldier checkmate ok Wow a really fresh
eyes blind here yeah this is also it but
I have that move I have that move check
wow talk about crazy fatigue now I'm
winning right and this this is also
winning according to the engine with the
King even capturing that check typical
computer stuff check checkmate so cute
self made that you can still fall into
check and this is winning check wider it
cannot defend the insta mate I used to
give up a screen which means that that
I'm winning that are winning the whole
time but I didn't get it I really did I
thought I'm checkmated here but I'm
winning yeah okay if the maid is not
working then I am winning it's Janet
clear and the way it went I'm just
retching all that storm check you know
and where the comp even gives g4 but
that's not not a very human wheelchair
this is winning but ok this is a time
it I mean okay maybe something like that
check to stall me but I might manage
yeah this is six seconds this is a lot
lots of pre moves maybe I would still it
was very nice of him to resign then oh
wow there was really a lucky game I
didn't see much and I go to lucky
winning okay well thanks for watching